how do you end a world war using a
weapon of mass destruction will
definitely help the u.s. dropped the
first ever nuclear bomb on the city of
Hiroshima on August the 6th 1945 killing
up to 80,000 people instantly and
injuring roughly the same number the
blast leveled the city the president at
the time justified using the bomb saying
we have you didn't order dessert in the
agony of war his point was that an
invasion of Japan would result in over a
million US casualties a point of
contention today but the u.s. wasn't
done three days later it dropped the
second nuclear bomb on the city of
Nagasaki and there were at least 50,000
casualties shortly after that Japan's
surrender bringing world war ii to a
close
so with the nuclear attacks on Japan
justified or simply crimes against
humanity
[Music]